we've been covering the global supply
chain bottlenecks making things
difficult for holiday shoppers according
to one survey 77 of you out there say
you've experienced product related
shopping problems and nearly half of
those survey respondents say it was
because items were either out of stock
or back ordered to make things worse
scammers are taking advantage of these
difficulties
by setting up fake websites scammers
gonna scam that's why we got our
consumer investigative correspondent
anna werner here with some tips on how
to thwart them anna good morning good
morning tony yeah and you know most of
us
are doing at least some of our holiday
shopping online and the scammers know it
it's their big season too their goal for
you to give them a present your money
iowa high school senior jace leniger
likes music in particular artist billy
eilish so when the singer-songwriter
released her new album over the summer
he decided to buy himself a birthday
gift of some of her new merchandise on
what looked like her bona fide website i
started looking around and shopping he
bought a bundle he'd seen on instagram
with a sweatshirt poster and other items
price tag about a hundred dollars but
when the transaction hit his bank
account he says it showed some 79
dollars which he found suspicious
and so after that i started to look up
the website look up reviews on the
website and
there are over like a thousand people
reviewing this website saying it's a
scam don't buy it i haven't gotten my
stuff in over half a year so
what has happened in terms of your money
and your merchandise well i don't have
the merchandise or my money he's just
one of thousands of consumers who say
they've lost money to scammers posing as
legitimate online retailers we have seen
a two thousand percent increase over the
past three months driven by the supply
chain issues
that are in this country today
lexisnexis risk solutions ceo haywood
talkove says that equals over 5000 fake
sites up from just 100 or so earlier
this year as criminals take advantage of
consumers need for products now in short
supply what's happening is when you go
to some of the big box stores they don't
have the toy that you want in stock
and then you google it and then you find
this really boutique company
that is offering the bicycle that your
daughter wants
and you think you know what i'm gonna
get it it really isn't a company
it's run it's a front for a
transnational criminal group and david
holushko with the secret service cyber
fraud task force says those criminals
fake sites typically launched from
overseas are becoming increasingly
sophisticated or they you know they
they learn as they go just like you and
i it's their job but examine sites
closely he says and there are often
tip-offs misspellings grammar mistakes
links on the page that don't work and a
refusal to accept credit cards
and these websites will often
only ask for payment via
a
a wire service such as paypal
venmo zell services that where the
transaction is put through those monies
are gone and it's very unlikely almost
impossible for the consumer to get their
money back it's like a virus it just
spreads it doesn't stop until the
consumers
stop falling for the trick
well telcov there with lexus nexus
estimates consumers here will have 20
billion dollars with a b
stolen by the end of the holiday season
so you know
it's a lot of money and people are
vulnerable i've been vulnerable to this
myself when you've got a to-do list
you're just trying to knock it down and
you're rushing through and you don't pay
attention to things that should tip you
off right and so that's the thing you
need to slow
down
ask yourself if none of the major
websites have this one toy you're
looking for this one product why does
this one little odd boutique site that
you never saw before have it
guess what they probably don't um go to
the store sites directly instead of
going through you know the search engine
for example when you search on google or
another website and those top three
things that come up a lot of time those
are paid sponsored sites and guess what
scammers can get their paid sponsored
site up to up to
no you can't because they they know to
pay for those um you can also google the
name of the website and the word scam
and a lot of times you'll find reviews
from people saying guess what this is a
scam and of course there's always the
mention of if it's too good to be true
if it looks too good to be true it is
yeah or do what i do just email anna
warner